CS2 is fully and truly upon us the last
ever CSG go hltv top 20 is drawn to a
conclusion and the first ever CS2 major
is almost here but the transition has
been far from seamless rosters are in
flux the game itself is still ironing
out some Kinks and craziest of all the
greatest Global Offensive player to ever
touch the game isn't well playing a lot
is changing and we're
simple
[Music]
all right so before we dive into the
video just wanted to remind all of you
beautiful talented Counter-Strike lovers
that we the score orts have a faic clan
it's totally free to join links in the
description you get a real ass anti-che
points to spend in the faet shop and a
Hardy funloving gameplay experience so
yeah simple for those who don't know and
I can't imagine that's many of you a few
months back the inimitable Sasha cosf
announced that he would be taking a
break from competitive Counter-Strike 2
to some this didn't come as a surprise
given that he like many of us had been
airing his frustrations about the game
for quite some time but it does beg the
question where is our goat why did he
take a step back and what's he been up
to in the meantime well for starters his
reasons for wanting to take a breather
in the first place are probably only
partly related to CS2 itself and just as
much a symptom of some real life stuff
that he made clear he is actively to
figure out how much this has to do with
the ongoing war in Ukraine and how much
disruption it's caused in he and his
family's life who's to say but the point
is that he probably had reasons outside
of shitty net code for wanting to take a
step back he did make clear that Upon
returning he'd entertain the idea of
abandoning the op in favor of a rifle
and even playing for an org other than
na'vi but we'll have to wait and see now
all things considered I do think it's
fair to at least wonder what is at stake
in simple taking such a significant step
back from competition now obviously he
is coming back he's made that clear but
the qualifiers for the major are
unfolding as we speak imagine the first
ever CS2 major happens and simple isn't
there to compete imagine zyu wins his
second major in a row and simple's not
there to put up a fight homie took
seventh on last year's hltv ranking
which by simple standards is pretty much
Unthinkable but there is the obvious
caveat that he literally has zero
recorded officials in CS2 which like I
mean let's be honest the guy took
seventh on the hltv ranking in spite of
having never played a single
professional match of CS2 that is the
most gangster I've ever heard
anyway I'm obviously not suggesting that
like simple's Legacy is like slipping
away or anything I'm just saying that
his absence means something zyu is all
but guaranteed to secure his third hltv
number one and he's already getting a
head start on 2024 if he ends 2024 as
number one that gives him four number
ones the most of any player in history I
know I'm getting a little ahead of
myself but the first major in March man
like that's a quarter of the year if
simpol is going to reinsert himself into
the show then he should probably do it
sooner rather than later we still have
no idea what position he's going to play
or what org he'll even be able to play
for and that's leaving aside all of the
catching up he'll have to do
statistically of course he could just
make his triumphant return next week and
none of this would B and trust me
nothing would make me happy he could
also just very well come back to na'vi
take over a rifling spot and leave
wonderful on the op or he could join a
whole other or who knows either way the
game doesn't feel the same without the
goat CS isn't CS without simple as for
what else is going on the new liquid is
the hypest thing I have ever hyped
Beyond psyched for that roster top Lads
all around dangerously high levels of
copium when it comes to cheering for the
new liquid ph's Frozen pickup was
extremely good and honestly just about
the only thing that could suitably repl
Place twists that dude has deserved to
play on a world class roster since
basically the day he entered tier 1cs
Vitality looks amazing with Mesi and the
fact that he's English just makes the
whole thing that much funnier Falcons
turned out sort of kek w which is also
funny but I'm genuinely curious to see
what they can do I really like sunas and
snappy as the goat so even in light of
their dubious funding it's sort of hard
to cheer against the roster itself my
biggest hope for the immediate future
though is that complexity are just able
to keep this momentum train rolling I
love that a is back on top form and is
just carrying like the good old days
that roster is really fun to cheer for
and I just hope they keep growing
scratch that my actual biggest hope is
that when simple does make his return he
really really plays up the theatrics and
like actually gives us a Michael Jordan
ass I'm back moment that if anyone else
did it would be kind of cringe but
because he's actually simple he can get
away with that kind of thing so yeah
fingers
crossed you know what I want the
announcement of you know would be the
only thing cooler let's try to think
what would be the sickest announcement
what would be the sickest return simple
could possibly make like simple joins
Team Liquid simple has
replaced gumay Yushi on T's League of
Legends roster